[Music]
tired of living on an overpopulated
earth why not move to the O'Neill
cylinder an artificial state-of-the-art
space habitat where we can control
everything including the weather what
would it take to build a space station
like this how big would it be and how
would we make it suitable for life this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we could build an O'Neill cylinder
when physicist Gerald K O'Neill came up
with the idea of his space colony in
1974 people thought he was crazy back
then a cylinder floating in space didn't
seem like a space habitat anyone would
want to move to but fast forward to our
time the world has grown by four billion
people climate change is on the rise
moving to a Space Station doesn't seem
so crazy anymore huh now this
far-fetched idea inspires wealthy
dreamers like Jeff Bezos who is looking
into building enough O'Neill cylinders
to board one trillion people but how
exactly would this work the idea behind
the O'Neill cylinder Space Station is
simple it would be a rotating Space
Station about six and a half kilometers
in diameter and 26 kilometers in length
to build a structure that size we
wouldn't need to collapse all the
planets in the solar system like we
would for some of the other space mega
structures lining our moon and some
nearby asteroids should be enough to
provide us with all the materials we
need
we'd assemble the cylindrical station
right in space somewhere between the
earth and the moon we park the O'Neill
cylinder at a Lagrangian where it would
stay in place without being drawn into
the orbit of either the Earth or the
moon constructing the O'Neill cylinder
would be one thing but we'd also need to
make it habitable that means giving it
gravity water and a breathable
atmosphere gravity would be easy the
cylinder would make a full rotation in
two minutes that would generate a
centripetal force which we would
experience as gravity to make the
structure more stable and prevent it
from drifting away we need to build two
counter-rotating cylinders connected at
each end we design the space habitat to
mimic Earth's air pressure at sea level
and the built in aluminum mirrors would
give us control over the amount of
sunlight getting inside the habitat we'd
be able to set our own day and night
cycle and manage the temperature inside
the O'Neill cylinder to this space
habitat would be powered by solar energy
gathered by all the solar panels
covering the outer cylinder we'd create
artificial mountains valleys and forests
we'd bring in water derived from icy
comets
to get around the cylinder we'd use
cable cars or you could simply ride a
bike it would be like a mini earth but
with us having complete control over its
climate all that would take six years
and a few trillion dollars to build and
if you don't want to give up your home
on earth for some space habitat the
O'Neill cylinder would make a great
vacation spot
welcome to O'Neill cylinder one where
there's no gloomy weather and where all
your food is grown at a local farm climb
up our artificial mountain and enjoy a
great view from our space habitat for
the low low price of course there would
be some challenges we'd have to get
really good at recycling all the waste
aboard the space habitat or it would
quickly turn into a space garbage bin
then there are the asteroids we'd have
to keep track of how much damage they
caused when they hit the O'Neill
cylinder so that the situation doesn't
get out of hand and you know this isn't
the only thing we should consider to
make the O'Neill cylinder a safer place
to live if you want to know more check
out what if discussed where we talked to
an assistant professor of biomedical
engineering at UC Irvine Ron K Orlov
easy about the challenges of bringing
people to a space station like this just
tap on the link
you